make his fourth appearance in the preseason for
the Devils it's the third start in the preseason
for ilas soken the puck is down exhibition game
number six of six has begun for the New York
Islanders their final test Tage Thompson who we we
will see eight days from now on opening night but
butch uh what a player in Ryan poock he really
can do it all on the back end hey he really can
bring some offense but I was just impressed with
his defensive play and there's a goal the Devils
take a one- nothing lead on that redirection from
Max Wilman who is in Camp on a PTO well get a goal
and there's a the faceof win and pel just not able
to uh I believe was not able to ever catch up to
him that was excuse me Noah doson just didn't blck
him out early enough and then never was able to
catch him up and then a quick little deflection
and Soka just couldn't dling get squeezed against
the glass now Clutterbuck with the hit there
he's likely to play his 1,000th National Hockey
League game just a couple of months shot here gets
through knocked to the corner could be as early as
late November for Cal Clutterbuck as he approaches
that Milestone this season he'll touch it in and
Schmidt out of his net will Propel it [Applause]
around the pace has slowed down a little bit here
things settling down the Devils leading one to
nothing nozer in sends it across Mercer with
a shot kicked away soken fcks out that right pad
made the stop amberella back down low here Romanov
he'll get out the eight iron flips it to center
fell down for Paul Mary gosier The Stick of Kevin
ballos flying he wants a penalty non called and
the Devils Rush up ice they've got numbers for
a second Mercer kept to the outside by poock in
front jamming away is schmelzer and sokin makes
it disappear turnning for the Devils one thing
about them is they have great transition as you
mentioned Allan a parel three on two Romanov
loses his man there I mean he's kind of stayed
with his man it was a three on two don't go in
behind the net but it's in front of the net wide
open so that that's a mistake by the Islanders and
that's the one the coaches are another team that's
gotten a lot better and has High Hopes is Detroit
this Eastern Conference will be very interesting
this season of course of course both New York
teams the Devils all made the playoffs last year
amazingly and they could do it again this season
here's a two-on one for the Islanders barzel Bice
has horat in shot and that one squeezed against
the pads of Schmid something the fans will want
to see more and more often that puck just flips
up on both Colin Miller the former Dallas star
was acquired on July the 1st for a fifth round
pick from Dallas walstrom back in reaches back
didn't get a lot on it shot the stop the rebound
was there Schmid made another save on Lee stays
right with it and then gets his feate movement I
love that part and wall he's going to hang onto
it a little quick little shot rebound Islanders
driving to the net looking for the loose stuff
so Islanders starting to generate a little more
with the half minute to go in the period thr to
the front Schmid stops it and he will cover it up
before Lee can do anything with it not necessarily
that those guys on the list didn't make an
impression or an impact but a lot of those
guys fighting to make an impression because they
want to be the first guys called up well and and
that's that's those are two important assets to
to be a penalty killer so I I can understand them
wanting to see what else he can do an advantage
with the he's got such a long stick too that can
that can really swallow off a lot of lanes out on
the ice so you know I think it's good opportunity
to get him involved and see what he can do on the
FI I'll tell you what Hicks watching Bridgeport
as much as I have the last few years Simon
Holstrom was a St people on the penalty kill
for a couple of years down in Bridgeport played
well certainly can fill that role here at this
level too Doon the Paso across Lees all alone
Cuts in he triying to go five ball on the back
hand emit ahead it's right on the stick of smelzer
in over the line dropped it for Mercer he's got an
opening Mercer across one time shot they score
it's ball and it's a two nothing lead for the
devils a quick transition for the Devils as we've
seen in the past he covers up that five hole but
Islanders got numbers back and again Mercer
wins the battle one-onone and now sorokin's
in trouble cuz that's as you mentioned Thomas
that's an East West pass sorokin's got a long
ways to come doesn't establish position now Joe
didn't get all that one but it did the job gets
it deep nit around the boards and back out to
Center as AO couldn't keep the line go he's
tripped up and time trip yeah this time they're
not going to call it and then here's Nemitz who
has his step he scores that's too bad guys he
stuck his foot out it was a trip for sure yeah
the referee's missed one there's no doubt there
he doesn't skate that way Ty Thompson got a got
away with one there and then look at the good
move as he continues to to skate kept his feet
moving and a nice nice goal final year of a
two-year deal for Sebastian AO and NHL career
highs in goals assist points games played last
season here's Lee between the circles shuffles
one wide goer good work to get it out High to
barzel barzel takes it around looks here's goer
back door and a shot that smid bought off went
straight up into the air the Islanders bring it
down saw homes from there on that
shot that he had earlier tonight
a bit of a a missed opportunity and
those three on the ice to start the
third and you try to learn from that and
say you know what I need to get my head
up merer off the face off nit and Rella swings it
below the goal line mon off Le passes targeting
Lee picked off and is shot in tight sroi made a
fine save Mercer again Slap Shot kicked away oh
this is happening simply because the Hors
turned the puck over you're getting your
wish though Butch plenty of work for be careful
what you wish for is that what you're saying th
that's right there's nothing I hated more than
sitting around and practicing while everyone
gets to play I think for this group it like I said
the anticipation builds look at this shorthanded
it's cus and he can't beat Schmid closing in on
the forehand the big stop well look at the good
stick work by excuse Clutterbuck and then good
little pass to Casey Casey's got his head up the
way but there's the thing on breakaways Thomas
you have have to give the golender something to
think about KY goes in and makes one move and
then shoots right away when he got control in
his own Zone but he he knew he had time he
waited and knew Casey was going to be going
up the middle and gave him a nice little play as
Jones splits the Gap and shoots on wi we'll burn
off some time fourth power play of the night for
the New York Islanders tripping on schmelzer was
trying to clean up that rebound Cloud against
a shot off shanding sokin not interested in a
face off in his own zone so he plays it and
doson carries it ahead Elson in Schmid stops
it behind his net and then continues it along no
sec to Smith and here's Mercer in shorthanded a
breakway for the devils and a good P save for
sok Nelson hits palmy what look at there's the
fake to the for to the to his backand and then
back to the forehand he talk about having to
give the golender something to think about that's
exactly what Mercer did gave him a little fake on
the forehand then went back to this forehand
Dobson Slap Shot knock down where is it Schmid
Dives on top of the puck just outside the crease
Brendan will be will be back and we'd be remiss if
we didn't remind people that uh Brendan misses us
and uh I don't know where he is this this weekend
Madison Wisconsin doing college football there
home of the the Badgers tomorrow he told me he's
been home a whole lot more this summer sitting by
the pool no second had hold didn't use him doing
great things named the rink after Islanders
Legend Ed Ed Westfall doing uh doing lots of
good things yeah good opportunity for kids out in
East now to to be able to play hockey oh it's a 30
save shut out for Akira Schmid the Islanders fall
tonight three nothing to conclude the pre-season